rocket League sales continue to soar I'm
Dave and welcomes your Premiership
gamespot news update the soccer with
cars game now has generated more than 70
million dollars in revenue from the
playstation 4 and pc versions sine x
marketing executive Jerry Dunham said in
a recent interview thunnie that this
figure is up from around 50 million
dollars from just two months ago also
during the interview done revealed that
rocket League has now sold four million
copies across ps4 and PC he explained
this figure does not count copies
downloaded from when rocket League was
free on PlayStation Plus earlier this
month Sonic's announced a rocket League
total player base stood around 11
million people that would seem to
suggest that seven million copies of the
game were downloaded for free during
July 2015 whatever the case rocket
League is a big hit and sales stand to
grow further still as the game was just
recently released on xbox one in
addition to revenue from game sales
Sonic's makes money from DLC sales for
rocket Lee's for dollar expansion packs
such as supersonic fury chaos run
revenge of battle cars and additionally
the Back to the Future pack and the
Batman V Superman car pack coming in
March excitingly psionics are also
releasing a physical copy of rocket
League at retail in the future so you
still playing the car based sports ball
let us know in the comment section below
or find me on Twitter at irregular Dave
and for all your gaming and
entertainment news stay tuned to
gamespot com